in late 1867 Alaska was transferred from
the ownership and dominion of the
Russian Empire to the United States of
America it was sold for the princely sum
of 7.2 million dollars and for most it's
just a footnote in history a question
that should be asked is why did Russia
decide to sell its overseas colony
furthermore why did it sell it to the
United States and why not say Britain or
some other colonial power so the primary
reason for the sale of Alaska was
Russia's defeat in the Crimean War the
war had done several things the first
was that it had largely bankrupted
Russia which was struggling to repay the
debts it had racked up in order to fight
the war the second was that the
victories of the Royal Navy over the
modernizing Russian Navy had made it
clear that Russia a long way to go
before it could challenge Britain at sea
as such it was realized by the Russian
leadership that shoot another War break
out there was little to stop Britain
from simply conquering the territory via
Canada so what type of territory was
Alaska for a start it wasn't called
Alaska at the time but simply Russian
America and for the Russian Empire it
provided several things first of all was
the prestige that came with owning an
overseas territory as for its economic
benefits Alaska was a much more mixed
bag which combined with the cost to
protect it you can see why the sale was
seen as necessary incidentally the sale
of Russian America was broached by
Emperor Alexander the second brother the
Grand Duke Constantine who wanted to
strengthen and liberalize the empire in
the wake of the defeat in the Crimean
War it didn't take much to convince the
Emperor to agree to the sale but now the
question was to whom
well Britain was an obvious contender
given that its North American lands were
already attached to Russian America and
they already had the right to navigate
its waters and trade with the colony so
why didn't they sell to Britain well
Russia and Britain were Imperial rivals
and to give Britain a large coastline so
close to Russia was potentially
dangerous also Britain wasn't interested
since Canada is already huge and Britain
had enough access to the Pacific Ocean
thus the United States of America was
really the only likely candidate for the
purchase Russia had approached the u.s.
in the early 1860s concerning the
purchase but they were undergoing this
little-known event could the American
Civil War and so were a bit busy after
the war was settled and the US had to
deal with the issues of reconstruction
the purchase of Alaska was seen as a
useful distraction the Russian Empire
was also keen to keep up the ongoing
good relations with the Americans
because as an ally they would be useful
it was agreed in march 1867 between the
governments of the US and russia that
alaska would be bought
how did they come up with the price well
Russia had sent a team of surveyors to
look for things like natural resources
and to see how good life in Alaska was
and it was determined that Alaska was
worth about ten million dollars however
the survey is argued that Alaska
shouldn't be sold at all and that the
governance of it simply be reformed the
emperor ignored this and both sides
negotiated until the sum of 7.2 million
was agreed in October 1867 it was
transferred to America and Russia's
attention would thereafter be focused at
the south and to the west I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patrons
that you see on screen now and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette party-boy Co
szarka flash chris wicker Rob Waterhouse
Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan Maggie
packs Kowski Winston K word rafail Adam
Harvey
Anthony Beckett Skye Chappell and the
amusement park Ives
you